اذا نطقتيه مستمره على العربيه وسنكون
معكم من كافه الجوانب لتغطيه ما حصل في
تركيا صباح هذا اليوم نتحدث عن زلزال قوته
7.9 درجات ضرب جنوب تركيا في ساعه مبكره
من صباح اليوم هذا الزلزال الذي وقع على
عمق عشره كيلومترات بالقرب من مدينه
كهرمان مرعش في جنوب تركيا طبعا هذا زلزال
لضرب الوسط التركي نتحدث عن جنوب تركيا
ولكنه امتد الى البلدان المجاوره حتى هذه
الساعه وفقا لمراسل العربيه لا تقارير عن
تسونامي بعد زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وطبعا
وفقا لما قال اليه مراسل العربيه خصوصا من
التحذيرات التي تتحدث بانه هناك تخوفات
وتحضيرات من موجه تسونامي بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا طبعا ننقل لكم المشاهد
والصور اولا باول لحظه وقوع الزلزال هذه
الان صور حصريه للع مباشره طبعا نتابعها
من اورفا ينقلها لنا الصحه في عهد الصليب
نتابع معكم هذه الصور وهو معنا طبعا الان
ليطلعنا على جديد الاخبار والصور عهد اهلا
بك معنا من قلب الحدث الان نتابع الجرافات
ونتابع ايضا من الدفاع المدني لانتشال
الضحايا وايضا المباني المهدمه على ما
يبدو لك الكلمه عهد
نعم صباح الخير لك والاستاذ المشاهدين هذا
البناء في حي برشلونه دولار في وسط ولايه
شارلي اورفا التركيه مؤلف من خمس طوابق
سقط جميعه على الارض وهنا قبل قليل اثناء
عمليات يعني
رفع الركام على ما يبدو هذه جثه الان تظهر
امامنا
منعتنا وسائل
عمليات نعم الاطفاء والصحيه والشرطه من
الاقتراب اكثر الى هذا الركام خوفا على
يعني حياه المتواجدين خاصه حتى بعض
المنازل والابنيه المتواجده في بالقرب من
هذا البناء الذي سقط هي ربما ايضا تضررت
بشكل كبير وربما هي ايضا للسقوط في اي
لحظه الان يعني كما ترون العمليات
انتشال الجرحى والقتله تم نقلهم الى مشافي
المشافي الحكوميه داخل ولايه شارلي اورفا
اعداد القتلى في ولايه اورفا هو عدد اعداد
كبيره في هذا البناء قبل قليل احد
المصادر من الذين كانوا ينتشلون الجرحى
قال ان هناك ثلاث ضحايا سقطوا على الفور
في هذا المبنى وكذلك الامر عدد اخر من
هنا محاوله نعم اذا عمليات الانقاذ في
اورفا التركيه متواصله وطبعا وسط تضرر
العديد من الابنيه نتابع معكم هذه الصور
المباشره وحصريا لقناه العربيه من خلال
عدسه كاميرا الصحفي عهد الصليبي عهد لمن
لا يعرف جغرافيه التركيه يعني علمنا بان
الزلزال وقع في جنوب تركيا اليوم عندما
نتحدث عن ولايه اورفا بالتحديد اين تقع
بالتحديد ولماذا هي من ضمن الولايات
المتضرره في تركيا
اذا سمحت لي انا ابتعدت عن المكان بسبب ان
هناك
ماذا يزرع
بسبب ان هناك ربما بعض الجرحى ما زالوا
يحاولون الوصول الى صوتهم اسكتوا الجميع
وربما ايضا القوات الشرطيه حاولت ابعاد
الاهالي متواجدين في محيط هذا المكان الى
اماكن اخرى الان كما ترين هنا الاهالي
بداوا بالابتعاد بشكل عن هذا البناء على
ما يبدو ان هناك ايضا جرح ما زالوا تحت
الانقاب علما ان عمليه الزلزال او الزلزال
ضرب المنطقه قبل نحو ثلاث ساعات من الان
اعداد كما ذكرت لك في هذا البناء تحديدا
بحسب احد المصادر من الاطفاء انهم ثلاث
قتلى وعدد كبير من الجرحى